a
la vuelta de la escuela el 30 de agosto
en mexico no tiene marcha atrás mateo al
cierre encontrar a sus compañeros y su
mamá tiene más miedo a los efectos del
encierro que al coronavirus creo que es
importante con todas las medidas que ya
tenemos con toda esa comunicación que
vamos a tener llevarlos a la escuela
para que logren tener lo que lo que los
niños necesitan en la escuela lo que van
a socializar
mateo está contento y promete cuidarse
la verdad si necesitaba ir a la escuela
y pues ya lo voy a hacer las autoridades
limpiaron escuelas y establecieron
medidas sanitarias pero dado el auge de
la pandemia el regreso ha generado
polémica
a miembros de la disidencia magisterial
que 150 mil maestros rechazan la medida
y advierten que no asistirán
el presidente ha sido enfático en la
necesidad de volver a las aulas ya no es
posible tener a los niños encerrados
en las casas no es posible eso se les
está causando un gran daño la cantidad
de pedazos
pero al ser voluntario el regreso hay
papas que por ningún motivo llevarán a
sus hijos nora de demasiado riesgo la
verdad es que vale mucho la pena yo
prefiero tener a mis hijas aquí que
exponerlas a una enfermedad que no sé
cómo va a resultar y su hija dice estar
de acuerdo es más seguro más tranquilo
porque tampoco quiere enfermar a mis
abuelitos ya que nosotros nos hemos
estado cuidando mucho y para que vayamos
y desperdiciamos todo ese tiempo que
estuvimos aquí no vale la pena entonces
las autoridades descartaron aplicar
pruebas kobe y están conscientes de que
podrá haber contagios en los colegios
pero de darse el caso no van a cerrar
toda la escuela sino que harán una
intervención selectiva así será la
vuelta a clases universal y la más
complicada en la historia del país